herzlich und so neue leute ich saß heute
in meinem zimmer habe überlegen
sebastian was könnte eine neue hilft mir
folge seien über die du dich mal
amüsieren könnte und das ist meine idee
gekommen
zwar hat es bisher immer so gemacht dass
wir uns eigentlich immer so die neuesten
folgen herausgesucht haben das heißt ihr
seht ihr irgendwo aufpoppen und schicken
dann auf insgesamt screenshots von dem
video in mainz wo sie was hier jemand
drauf den ganzen ort wenn du heute war
von hinten aufzäumen denn ich werde mir
heute mal einen der absoluten helfen ihr
klassiker auf oldtimer raussuchen und
dann mit euch schauen wir reden hier
über keinen kleinen fisch leute es geht
um das video psycho vater macht familie
das leben zur hölle 4,1 millionen
aufrufe und maniche wir uns jetzt an den
versuchen nachzuvollziehen warum vier
millionen menschen sich dieses video
angeschaut haben wie immer geht leute
unter den ersten zwanzig kommentaren
unter meinen videos verlose ich einmal
pro monat 51 auf einmal sehr gut
scheinen also wenn er bock drauf hat
macht die menschen seien unter den
ersten 20 im video
jetzt habe ich genug als die leute wir
starten rhein neckar okay das war schon
mal komplett wissen bei sekunde 6 von
diesem video
und ja es ist wirklich jetzt bereits
schon sehr schmerzhaft der typ auf der
linken der höchstwahrscheinlich der
psycho vater ist seine tochter vor dass
sie versucht habe sich zu prostituieren
alles klar
ich bin an der stelle aus weißt du was
du willst ein fleckchen deiner mutter
wir sind ja mächtig in fahrt heute zu
wenig ist damals jungen frau warter
krise haben 4,2 millionen menschen
dieses video angeklickt
wir können aber schon mal sagen heute
perfekt der familienvater macht es so
wie ein männliches familienoberhaupt das
machen sollte wirft der tochter vor dass
sie sich präsentieren wollte und
beleidigt die mutter läuft perfekt
okay leute einen blick in die
beschreibung verrät uns dass dieser typ
hier auf der linken der vater bernd ist
tatsächlich luna ist dieses junge
mädchen auf der rechten seite und ihre
mutter ist auch noch in fahrt
und ja ich muss wirklich sagen der vater
der wagen komplett im wasser
und
[Musik]
top top sicherheitsgefühl die mutter
kümmert sich auf jeden fall auch gut um
ihre tochter und steht für ihren schutz
in auf ihren selbst sein vater ist
komplett ausrasten literally schlägt
fast die fensterscheibe ein hat draußen
dann rufe ich die polizei ist alles gut
ja die hat mit dem wollte uns nur kurz
mit einer axt raum alles fiel kurz und
knackig vor die tür mit dem bernd so
geht es genau
und der zweite schritt der wäre jetzt
aber wichtig wirklich die polizei zu
holen sich unterstützung zu holen
also muss auch sehr bitten an der stelle
also die situation ist ja wie die mutter
de la garde schon gesagt hat eindeutig
im griff oder also warum die polizei
rufen gut ja es stimmt der familienvater
steht zwar im garten und ist kurz davor
die komplette wurde kurz und klein zu
schlagen aber das ist jetzt wirklich ein
grund sich aufzuregen
[Musik]
irgendwann freund mein vater bringt uns
um plus brüssel muss vollkommen also
eigentlich wollte ich dir nur mitteilt
dass unsere partner uns umbringen aber
plus plus extra noch dazu du musst
kommen also eigentlich müsste ich ja
nicht kommen wenn unser vater zum bringt
aber komm mal in diesem fall bitte
trotzdem will sie tot schlagen
irgendwann überhaupt hat eine
alltägliche situation meint hill mit
seinen punker freunden im park und dann
kommt mal wieder wahl wieder es nervt
wirklich mittlerweile heute die
nachricht von der folge dass ihr vater
sich dass menschen hat der kurz mal hat
den schädel einzuschlagen ja heute schon
wieder eine morddrohung ich muss los
ja also ich mein aus irgendeinem grund
habt ihr den ja so in euer leben
gelassen beziehungsweise er hat dich
luna ja sogar zeugt ist dein vater er
hat einen schlüssel zu dem außerdem noch
krank auch hier wieder leute top
decision making wirklich die
entscheidung die von den beiden die
getroffen werden sind allererste sahne
nummer eins natürlich wieder nicht die
polizei zu rufen ich meine ja was soll
was hier
der typ ist ja nur komplett geistig
gestört nummer zwei ist dieses wirklich
geniale verstrich ohne witz wenn man
sich anstrengen würde und versuchen
würde sie nicht zu sehen
es geht nicht es ist natürlich im gang
der reihe für das haus direkt tolles
versteckt
alter wie hätte die kraft gefunden
es geht es wie mir nicht den kopf rein
gehen leute aber er hat sich tatsächlich
gefunden und könnte jetzt möglicherweise
zum nachteil werden lassen sich dagegen
entschieden haben die polizei zu rufen
weil wie gesagt schaut euch den alten
bahnen der ist vom bett gestellt ohne
wird sollte ich weiß nicht also
vielleicht muss ich an der stelle auch
mal so ein public service namens wird
also quasi so man so eine hilfreiche
ansage machen also sorry
wieso hat er noch keiner die polizei
rufen muss los wurde also ohne wird
sollte ich weiß nicht ob das da draußen
irgendeinem von euch vielleicht in der
schwächeren form oder so was schon mal
passiert ist ruft die polizei ohne
willst also da gibt es gar keine
diskussion geben mir das noch weiter mit
anzusehen
top so gefühlt dreieinhalb stunden
nachdem die ganze sache dann tatsächlich
über die bühne gelaufen ist kommen dann
die punks zur rettung also sie muss
wirklich sagen so die
entscheidungsfindung in dieser familie
ist nicht alles zu schloss kurz mal vor
augen leute also die beiden haben sich
dagegen entschieden die polizei zu rufen
und haben sich dafür entschieden einen
tank schlägertrupp zu bestellen
ja lass das mal sagt ich werde jetzt
dafür sorgen dass mein beschissener
vater die lektion dafür lernt okay leute
world of wagner also es geht weiter
es werden weiterhin gute entscheidung
getroffen ich will ganz kurz auf was er
zu sagen oder sonst fühle ich mich
schlecht und zwar dieses thema häusliche
gewalt ist sehr sehr seriös und ich will
mich in gar keinem fall über die sache
an sich lustig machen sondern nur über
die schlechte darstellt okay okay da
kommen wir zum thema also luna hat sich
jetzt scheinbar mal nach dem 80.000
übergriff entschieden mal was zu
unternehmen was genau das sein so wissen
wir noch nicht mit sicherheit aber nicht
die polizei zu rufen und ihre mutter
zieht einfach mal so ne worden und an
badezimmerschrank davor haben wir gehört
zum guten ton oder zutage leute wir
wissen dass alle man kommt morgens ins
bad nach dem zähneputzen muss man
natürlich erstmal ein bisschen schnaps
hinter die bühne ballern
eine stunde später als bern fonds eine
beruhigung spaziergang zurück kommt ahnt
er nicht was ihn erwartet
also beruhigt hatte ich mich jetzt nicht
aber oder wird sollte er wirklich der
haarsträubende unsinn geht einfach
weiter er wirklich gestörter gewalttäter
wahrscheinlich kommt überhaupt nicht ob
sein leben klar was ist die lösung
beruhigungs spazieren die augen zu
treten
also läuft gut wir haben wir die polizei
in deutschland wo für die ganzen
steuergelder millionen oder um
milliarden die dafür draufgehen dass man
die 110 wählen kann
ich glaube ich rufe meine freunde und
die hauen dann meinem leiblichen
erzeuger eine bierflasche über den kopf
wachsen einfach mutter flasche nieder
gesprächen
leute immer nur in welcher welt leben
diese darsteller laufen so ganz
katholischen gegend wo ich wollte nur
sagen hab ich nie übertrieben in der wir
verstehen geben
ich glaube der ist tot so kein versuch
irgendwie zurück zu gehen denn irgendwie
zu realisieren wenn man schon denkt dass
der tod sei ein mitarbeiter spaziert ja
egal können wir nichts voneinander
fotos und hat schon mal ich hab das
schon tausend mal gemacht hat es noch
nie jemand gestorben
bitte was er hat jetzt schon tausendmal
leuten hinterrücks mit bierflasche über
kopf gezogen und es bis dato noch keiner
gestorben perfekt okay halt doch alles
klar also muss wirklich sagen diese
erfolge hat auf jeden fall nicht zu
wenige psycho andreas zitate aber ja es
geht absolut sinnlos weiter es hat immer
noch keiner die polizei gerufen
trotzdem freute jetzt einfach auf dem
spielplatz ok und bodys land erst mal
alle die da sind
guten tag wir kennen uns ja schon hier
sind ihre geleistete arbeit ich werde
jetzt hier übernehmen und werde mich da
sache jetzt annehmen
naja vielen dank für ihre arbeit danken
dass sie meine tochter eingesammelt
haben dank ihrer mithilfe als polizei
kann ich jetzt weiterhin damit
fortfahren meine familie behindert zu
schlagen also leute ohne willst was zur
hölle haben wir uns da gerade angeschaut
4,2 millionen aufrufe 4,2 millionen
deutschland ist nicht mehr zu retten
aber ja leute ich hoffe ihr hattet spaß
beim schauen dieses videos ich betone
mein gewissen weil ich finde das gehört
einfach so dazu korrekter weise kein
spaßiges thema an sich sollte ihr davon
betroffen sein
holt euch auf jeden fall hilfe von
außerhalb polizei oma opa whatever das
wasser weiter mir ich habe hier einfach
ich vorgeschlagen zwischen könnte man
carabiniere macht's gut und beruf die
polizei wenn es stress gibt es besser